another week another day in the
apocalypse and we have a show to talk
about not kidding though also spoiler
warning If You Haven't Seen the Last of
Us episode 2 on HBO it's out right now
I'm not going to talk about future
events in the game so if you haven't
played the game you don't know the plot
of the game entirely that's fine so The
Last of Us episode one aired last week
and all of us were pretty much like
well so far they've nailed it hope they
keep that up and after the second
episode gotta say they're doing a good
job I feel like I keep saying these
things to myself and on camera like well
so far I hope they keep it up because
what can I say we're all kind of like
Joel when it comes to Ellie like Joel to
Ellie is most of us to video game
adaptations or good shows in general we
don't want the hurt that comes from
caring too much if it goes bad because
we know how much that can suck now both
of these episodes the first two episodes
of The Last of Us they've started out
before civilization fell in the pilot
episode it was Joel hanging out with his
daughter and then you see everything go
to [__] in the second episode it deals
with this biologist it's pretty much
like can you tell us what this is and
she's like bomb the city kill Millions
to save billions that's what you need to
do I don't know if they're gonna keep
that up episode episode seems to be the
pattern if you're looking at the first
two anyway when I was watching this
flashback scene at the beginning of this
second episode I was like this does give
me that Chernobyl feeling you know you
got that Chernobyl flavor in here it
looks like I'm watching a biopic about
what started the apocalypse thus far
I've enjoyed watching it I would want an
hour in the apocalypse and anytime you
spend in the flashbacks in the past
we'll just tack that on to the hour in
the apocalypse but this is the episode
where it's the Showcase of what makes
video game adaptations to live action so
difficult because you have to show
recognizable locations recognizable
gameplay all the while having it be a
drama amazing how many adaptations of
[__] that up royally and I thought the
second episode did a really good job at
showcasing The Last of Us when they're
walking through the ruins of the city
sometimes I was like that's really
impressive other times I was like that
is a set with a green screen so I like
seeing what I recognized in The Last of
Us the hotel the ruined City in live
action but to the point of having to cut
things out even if they are iconic when
they got into the hotel I was like is
Joel gonna find the safe code you gotta
find the safe code if you're gonna get
into the safe no because why would he be
looking for a safe code he's trying to
get through this building there are no
plot trophies in the apocalypse Living
Through The Experience that's your plot
then they run into those clicker [__]
they get dancers to play they had to
have gotten dancers I challenge anyone
to mix Michael Jackson music to the way
these things were walking it will fit
I wasn't afraid of a copyright strike
I'd do it here but I can't so thus is
life but again in them doing a good job
at illustrating to the audience who
might not have played the game the
mechanics of the world they're dealing
with and Joel was like they can't see
but they can hear I feel like I'm kind
of cheating because I know these things
are blind but they have insanely good
hearing I feel like if you haven't
played the games you would have gotten
that pretty early on in the situation if
you haven't played the game and you've
seen the show well let me know guess we
can clear that up right now with
audience interaction then the thing
here's Joel Joel shoots at it misses the
headshot completely which I can relate
to only thing is live action Joel does
not have the advantage of being able to
load his previous save he's just kind of
stuck with whatever ever happens that
sucks and this episode really hammers
home how important the sound design to
The Last of Us is I talked about how
important the music was in the previous
episode I talked about the music the
visuals the sound design of the monsters
like they didn't make that weird
clicking sound it wouldn't feel the same
it wouldn't be the same monster glad HBO
wasn't like did we do anything with
zombie sound effects so we can just roll
in some zombie sound effects well
they're not technically zombies in The
Last of Us sure but it's fine same
concept there is a genuine sense of care
and wanting to preserve that which makes
the world of The Last of Us and I really
like what they did with anatorevist I
figured I'd talk more about her when she
you know bites it
or it bites her
I'm cutting that out but when I saw her
in the first episode I was like Has
Olivia done him from Fringe I know she's
been in a lot of other stuff but I'll
always know her as Olivia Dunham from
Fringe what an underrated show that was
completely
scratch that X-Files itch but I enjoyed
them building the test Joel dynamic in
here when I was playing the game I was
like look Tess I know you're not on the
box cover so just waiting for you to die
so we can move on with the Stars it's
pretty much where I am with you maybe
I'm just cold but when Tess died I was
like yeah it's very sad Annie who let's
kill some Infected what do you say oh
they're not infected they're just douche
bags we'll kill them too but I felt like
Tess in here you really got a sense of
the relationship between her and Joel
their partnership and when she died it
wasn't just like hey I'm gonna give you
some time and then they go around like
oh she's dead that sucked so to be fair
to me the game kind of executed it that
way when she died but she went out a
little differently for the most part I
get the changes but in the game it was
troops actually show up they're like all
right get out hands on your head drop
your weapons in this one it was a bunch
of infected coming to the building which
I I get that change there's a lot coming
at you in the game if you're playing 20
hours of gameplay totally works but in a
show that's shorter in an episode that's
an hour you gotta streamline some stuff
so dealing with the clickers and dealing
with troops it would have been a lot I
deal with clickers than infected let's
just deal with the dangers that are
outside the quarantine zone for now
she's like all right I'll blow him up
give you some time then she's like oh
God it's doing that movie thing it's not
lighting
[__] then she starts making out with the
infected there then drops the lighter at
lights and boom the whole time though I
was like
why didn't Joel and Ellie at least take
a couple of grenades maybe the next
episode will start out with them being
like hey I snuck a couple grenades how
smart am I but it was a great episode it
was an episode that had scenes and
moments from the game that you recognize
locations that you remember doesn't
linger in them for the sake of nostalgia
it still feels organic like yeah we're
just getting through these things these
buildings to get to the other side to
get out so we can live Nostalgia is a
byproduct of it it's not using Nostalgia
of the game to sell the show I do
appreciate that but also has some great
character building moments easy to view
Joel like Malcolm Reynolds from Firefly
he suffered a loss he has his walls up
because he doesn't want to give a [__]
that much ever again but in there in
those eyes you see a human being you can
root for so far The Last of Us on HBO
it's two for two on episodes and that
ain't bad I got that feeling when it was
time to watch The Last of Us that
excited feeling was like oh The Last of
Us is on you push play can't wait to
watch it that feeling that only comes
when you have a great show to look
forward to week to week alright so The
Last of Us episode have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]